the first thing you notice about someone
is their eyes so we have star secrets to
keep them looking gorgeous and ageless
remember when it was like all the rage
of the 90s like the stars where I'd
cream under their eyes it dad that
actually doesn't work so people are
still doing that so hemorrhoid cream it
just takes away the puffiness but often
it has menthol in it so it burns your
eyes a lot so it's not ideal
what else are people using at home to
reduce fine lines dark circles aging hi
Athena so basically they'll just put a
spoon in the refrigerator and hold it
under their eyes for you same ideas
putting cucumbers on your eyes I've
heard people putting egg whites and when
you put it on it congeals and tightens
so your under eye looks great for a few
minutes since these remedies have only
short-term effects we teamed up with dr.
Guan che and ROC skincare to reduce the
signs of aging without emptying your
pockets what exactly does the ROC
retinol correction I could do it's
clinically proven to visibly reduce fine
lines by 50% it visibly reduces
puffiness and dark circles within four
weeks the secrets out anyone can use
this product you can get it at Walmart
for under $20 do you have a way that you
suggest everyone put on their eye cream
just gently Pat it on with your fourth
finger and you pat it on it helps helps
you not create more wrinkles but add the
active ingredient to your skin
[Music]